مساء الخير لو سئل طالب العلاقات الدوليه
ان يلخص طبيعه العلاقه بين الولايات
المتحده ودول منطقه الخليج يمكن ان يحصل
على الدرجه النهائيه اذا كتب كلمه واحده
فقط البطوله البترول هو اللي بيحكم
العلاقه بين الولايات المتحده ودول
المنطقه سواء شرق الخليج العربي اللي هي
ايران او غربها الدول العربيه لكن السؤال
المطروح ليس فقط خارج الولايات المتحده
ولكنه مطروح من الوقت الاخر داخل الولايات
المتحده لامريكا متمسكه بشده او حريصه جدا
على حمايه تدفق النفط الخليجي رغم انها
ليست في حاجه الى امريكا الان اصبحت اكبر
منتج للبترول في العالم
المنطقه دافع بعض السياسيين داخل الولايات
المتحده انهما يطلبوا البيت الابيض انه
يعني يخرج من منطقه الخليج عسكريا وسياسيا
او يقلص هو ده ويخلص كل التبعات التي
تترتب على دعوه الولايات المتحده بحمايه
الدول المنتجه للبترول في المنطقه
والكلام ده اللي صناعه الرئيس الامريكي
الحالي
عن دخول البيت الابيض لكن سرعان ما غير
رايه يغير رايه غير الراي لنفس الاسباب
اللي دفعت الرؤساء الامريكان المتعاقبين
منذ نهايه الحرب العالميه الثانيه والى
الان واللي كانوا مصرين على الالتزام
بحمايه منطقه الخليج لضمان استمرار تدفق
النفط من المنطقه الى المستوردين كانت
مصالح الولايات المتحده
في النفط الخليجي بعض الحرب العالميه
التاليه بعد الحرب اثناء الحرب العالميه
الثانيه وقبلها وبعدها الولايات المتحده
لم تكن دوله فقيره
من حيث مواردها في النفط كانت في فتره من
الفترات ثلث انتاج العالم من النفط هذا
الوقت فندق حوالي سطاشر في المائه من
اجمالي انتاج العالم ورغم ان يتم غاليه
جدا بالنفط ولا تحتاج الى قطر النفط واحده
من دول الخليج لكنها كانت شديده الحرص على
ان تتواجد في منطقه الخليج وعملت البيت او
الاتفاقيه الشهيره مع السعوديه ثم مع باقي
دول الخليج الى سببين اساسيين
السبب الاول ان ي توفير النفط الى حلفاء
سواء في اوروبا او في منطقه
تحديدا الياباني اللي كانوا محتاجين اللي
بتقول بشده في عمليه اعاده الاعمار بعد
الحرب العالميه الثانيه
2 قطع الطريق على الاتحاد السوفياتي اللي
كان راغب في السيطره ايضا على المنطقه
وبالتالي السيطره على منابع النفط في
الخليج لكن الاتحاد السوفياتي هو كمان ما
كانش في حاجه الى البترول كان مهم للبطوله
زي الولايات المتحده لكن كان تقديري
الولايات المتحده ان السفير يسعون للسيطره
على منابع النفط في المنطقه اللي تحتوي
على حوالي النصف احتياطات العالم من
البطوله مش الاحتياجات الخاصه ولكن
لاستخدامه كورقه ضغط على حلفاء الولايات
المتحده في اوروبا او في اه اسيا وبالتالي
كانت حريصه انها تقطع عليه الطريق وقطعت
عليها الطريق قطعت عليها الطريق ازاي
بالنهايه منذ على مدار سبعين سنه طبقت
اشكال مختلفه من مبدا مونرو اه مبدا او
عقيده من في في في يعني السياسه الامريكيه
يعرف بعقيده الرئيس اللي هو الرئيس
الامريكي اللي كان بيحكم امريكا سنه الفين
وثلاثه وعشرين وابداها الامبراطوريه
الصاعده الجديده اللي هي الامريكيه اعلنت
انه وفقا لمبدا لن تسمح الولايات المتحده
باي تدخل او باي احتلال لاي من الدور اللي
موجوده في الامريكي الدين امريكا الشماليه
وامريكا الجنوبيه
يعتبرهم منطقه نفوذ امريكيه خالصه
الماده بدات امريكا تطبق بشكل او باخر على
منطقه الخليج بدايه من سنه خمسه واربعين
وخالد اشكال مختلفه يعني قبل سبعه وستين
مثلا
من نهايه الحرب العالميه الثانيه اللي سنه
سبعه وستين كان المسؤوله عن حمايه الخليج
الحليف الامريكي اللي هي اه البريطانيه
لغايه ما ضعفت بريطانيا وبقيه
يعني الاستمرار في وجودها خير حدودها فال
امريكا بدات تطبق اشكال اخرى كان اول شكل
اللي هو ما عرف بعقيده معقده تصدي باختصار
انه اه الولايات المتحده تبعها بحمايه
الخليج نعم ولكن من خلال الحلفاء او شركاء
محليين
واعتمدت على
الفناء ي اه الهند
ايران والسعوديه ظل الوضع على هذا النحو
لغايه الثوره الاسلاميه في ايران غازي
الاتحاد السوفياتي لافغانستان وقتها سقطت
تعقيد نيكسون لانه احد قضايا تتحول الى
عدو اللي هو ايران وكمان الاتحاد السوفيتي
اقترب جدا بقواته الى المنطقه في
افغانستان اظهرت ما يسمى ب عقيده كارتر
يعقد يعني ببساطه تقول ان الولايات
المتحده لن تسمح لاي دوله من دول العالم
بتهديد مصالح امريكا في المنطقه ولن تتردد
في استخدام القوه العسكريه
اذا اقدمت اي دوله على هذه الخطوه وفضلت
عقدت كارتر ظل الوضع يعني لسنوات موجوده
طبعا بما فيها حرب العراق او حرب الخليج
الاولى والثانيه اللي عاوزه اقول متعدده
الاشكال تعددت الاشكال
استراتيجيه الولايات المتحده في المنطقه
لكن القاده المشترك دائما كان انه
الخليج خط احمر رغم ان امريكا مش محتاجه
في معظم السنوات اللي يعني اله الحرب
العربيه التعليم وبما لما قال عمل
استراتيجيه ايضا الاستراتيجيه هي كانت
بتقوم على مصالحه اه ايران وعدم اقطاب دول
الخليج وتعهد لهم بحمايه في حاله تعرضهم
لاي خطر هو امدادهم بكميات كبيره من
السلاح لكن هذا لم يكن يرد دول الخليج
تطرف حول يصلح ما فعلوا اوباما يتعهد
بحمايه
الدول المنطقه عن طريق التحالف محلي يعني
اقرب الى عقله
لكن مش مكونه من دول الخليج وايران مكونه
من دول الخليج والدول الاخرى على راسها
اسرائيل اه بعد استبعاد ايران كانت
الاستراتيجيه الحادث الثابت انما في نسبه
هو الاول كانت الاستراتيجيه غير موجوده
لان كان فيه عدوه الرئيسي بيهدد دول
الخليج او ب يهدد الولايات المتحده
وينافسها على بترول الخليج اللي هو
الاتحاد السوفياتي طيب ما هو للتحدث في
اتفاق
صحيح لكن ظهر بعد الاتحاد السوفياتي عدو
اكثر خطوره على امريكا والصين للصين اكثر
خطوره تحدث في الدكان امبراطوريه ب تمتلك
كثير من مصادر القوه لكن كان تقدير امريكا
الاعداء نقطه ضعف واضحه وهو الاقتصاد
اه على سبيل المثال سنه التسعه وثمانين
كان الناتج المحلي الاجمالي للاتحاد
السوفيتي حوالي خمسمائه مليار دولار في
مقابل خمسه ونص او خمسه وسته من عشره
مليون دولار الولايات المتحده يعني لا
يوجد الى المقارنه انما في حاله العدو
الجديد اللي هو الصين اللي بدات تمثل مع
امريكا الجزء الثاني من فيلم ال بطور
العربي الاطراف المشهد هو هو المنطقه هي
الخليج العربي امريكا ما زالت البطل
الرئيسي في الفيلم
ايضا هي حريصه على لنفس اسباب التواجد في
منطقه الخليج لنفس الاسباب اللي كانت
موجوده في الاربعينات وهو توفير الخليج
بترول الخليج الى حلفاءها مش بالدرجه
الاولى لاوروبا اللي بتاخذ ثلاثين في
المائه من احتياجاتها من روسيا الان ولكن
بسبب خلافات هل موجودين في اسيا زي
اليابان وزير كوريا الجنوبيه ودي الفلبين
و وطبعا ال اوروبا الدول اللي في شرق اسيا
دول او الدول الاسيويه دى بتحصل على اكثر
من سبعين في المائه من احتياجاتها من دول
الخليج فهي الهدف رقم واحد الهدف الثاني
ان قطع الطريق على الصين الصين على عكس
الاتحاد السوفياتي الدوله اكثر كفاءه
اقتصاديا وهي يعني اصبحت مصنع العالم
وبالتالي عندهاش راها او اعطى الشديد جدا
للبترول العالم كله
وبتاخذ جزء كثير من احتياجاتها من بترول
من منطقه الخليج
وافريقيا وبالتالي فهي بتعتمد على البترول
ايديه من المنطقه وهي حريصه على اقامه
علاقات شراكه مع دول المنطقه وعملت
الشركات مع السعوديه ومع الكويت مع
الامارات مع كل دول المنطقه الحقيقه عمل
شركات متعدده جدا الامر الذي يحدد سيطره
الولايات المتحده على
منطقه الخليج ال الب وتعديل الولايات
المتحده وهي تركت الباب مفتوحا الصين
الصين لن تتوانى عن السيطره بالكامل على
المنطقه وبالتالي الحصول على كل المنطقه
على كل بترول الخليج
وحرمان حلفاء الولايات المتحده من البترول
العربي هو السيطره عليه لنفسها الامر اللي
بيوضع في الولايات المتحده وهي كمان بيدي
فرصه كبيره جدا او يعزز فرص صعود الصين
اللي هو بالفعل بيمثل
مصدر
كبير الامريكي يعني
امريكا وفق الارقام 2017 كان الناتج
المحلي الاجمالي الصين اطناشر حوالي
اثناشر واثنين من عشره مليار دولار وكانت
امريكا حوالي 19 مليار دولار ولو حسبناها
بمعادله القوى الشرعيه الا ان الولايات
المت نصين عندها الناتج المحلي الاجمالي
بتاع اكبر من الناتج المحلي الولايات
المتحده تقديرات البنك الدولي ان فترات 35
سيكون الناتج المحلي الاجمالي
بمعيار معادله القوه الشرعيه اللي تكلمنا
عليها بكره في حلقه ثانيه
حوالي ثلاثه واربعين مليار دولار
تريليون دولار في المقابل حوالي سته
وعشرين مليون دولار للولايات المتحده
امريكا مازال الخطر عليها من الصين اللي
اكبر من الخبر اللي كان بيمثلوا الاتحاد
السوفيتي وعلشان كده امريكا موجوده في
منطقه الخليج ولم تخرج منها وهي بتعزز قوه
بها في الفتره الاخيره قواتها مش بس لانه
هي عاوزه تقلل من مخاوف دول الخليج من
ايران علشان تعزز او تقل المخاوف من
الصعود الصيني من ناحيه وعلشان تقطع عليك
التاكد انهى في المكان اللي بيمثل اهميه
كبيره جدا
وفرصه كبيره
للصين يعني تقطع قطع الطريق على الصين
بوجودها في منطقه الخليج وده يحتل منها
حلقه ثانيه نشرح فيها
التحالف القائم الان ما بين الصين و روسيا
و ايران و خطه
الولايات المتحده لضرب التحالف اه اضعاف
انطلاقا من منطقه الخليج اشكركم ول لقاء
اخر ان شاء الله
[موسيقى]